porque la población mundial alcanza los
8 mil millones este 15 de noviembre de
2022 según el informe de perspectivas de
la población mundial se proyecta que en
la década del 2080 seremos alrededor de
10.400 millones de personas sin embargo
la población está creciendo a un ritmo
anual más lento desde 1950 por debajo
del 1% en 2020 Cuál es la incidencia del
aumento poblacional en la calidad de
vida y por qué preocupan además las
tasas de fertilidad para el análisis
sobre el tema se conecta con nosotros
Javi raboso él es sociólogo por la
universidad complutense de Madrid y
responsable de campañas de paz y
Derechos Humanos en greenpeace España
Muchas gracias a usted por estar con
nosotros en 2023 India superaría a China
como el país más poblado del mundo
porque hay Qué implicaciones tiene ello
para ambos países
tanto para esos países Buenos días tanto
para esos países como para el resto del
mundo las dinámicas de poblaciones es
decir los flujos las nacimientos de
funciones tasas de fertilidad y las
migraciones tienen un impacto sobre
precisamente los recursos globales de
los que contamos que cada vez más somos
conscientes de que son de que son
recursos limitados en este sentido
el crecimiento de la población es uno de
los factores que precisamente entran en
correlación con estos recursos limitados
pero es inevitable tener en cuenta
consideraciones como las que ya se han
comentado de Justicia climática o
plantearnos preguntas que son siempre
pertinentes como la cantidad de recursos
per cápita que en cada uno de los
lugares
pues se utilizan tantos de Electricidad
como de agua etcétera etcétera y los
movimientos efectivamente de población
las formas de asentamiento de población
en el cual
el asentamiento de población en mega
ciudades por ejemplo es tiene
consideraciones en cuanto a los recursos
disponibles muy diferentes a otros tipos
de asentamientos de población que no
juntan a 20 millones de personas en una
misma en una misma ciudad Claro pero ahí
hay una paradoja porque entre tanto la
fertilidad ha disminuido en las últimas
décadas en muchísimos países en la
actualidad son dos tercios de la
población no es mundial el que viven en
un país o en un área donde la fecundidad
es inferior al 2,1 hablando de
nacimientos por cada mujer Cuáles son
los problemas de no tener tantos
nacimientos como en el pasado y cómo se
reconcilia esto con la idea de que somos
demasiados en la tierra explotando los
recursos limitados
por un lado estas dos preguntas son
ciertamente pertinentes en este momento
en el que digamos aproximadamente se
calcula que podríamos llegar a esos
8.000 millones de personas por un lado
la tasa de bueno de reproducción que
está establecida entonces como a un
hijos por mujer efectivamente en países
especialmente en Asia en Norteamérica y
en Europa la mayor parte de países ya no
lo alcanzan esto no hace de suponer por
ser una problemática especialmente
combinado con la otra cuestión que es la
cuestión de si somos o no demasiadas
personas en el planeta por supuesto en
una bajo una perspectiva de marcada por
los Derechos Humanos no podemos decir
Somos demasiadas personas pero sí cabe
esta pregunta que de alguna manera choca
con algunos límites éticos de entender
abiertamente de si necesitamos seguir
creciendo este ritmo o no para esto no
hace falta aplicar políticas draconianas
y establecer límites de hijos por
mujeres etcétera etcétera Pero sí que ha
de ser bueno considerado pues
efectivamente como uno de los factores
que el que bueno se han observado más
efectivos al respecto que es la salud
resexual y reproductiva de las mujeres
en este sentido todos los feminismos y
el movimiento por la igualdad de género
tiene mucho decir sobre este aspecto hoy
en día hay aproximadamente anualmente
121 millones de embarazos que no son
deseados y cuando la experiencia la
historia nos dice que cuando son las
mujeres las que son capaces de decidir
sobre sus propios cuerpos las
estrategias de fecundidad por mujer o
las estaciones de natalidad de las
propias sociedades se regulan es por
esto que uno de los factores necesarios
es precisamente el de implementar las
políticas y las realidades de igualdad
de género en todos los lugares del
planeta
otro de ellos
sobre el que deberíamos hacer
insistencias precisamente la desigual el
desigual reparto de la riqueza y los
recursos que están asociados a cada una
de las personas como antes comentábamos
y que antes que si queréis podemos
profundizar también en ello claro es que
justamente quería ir hacia esa dirección
porque por ejemplo en este momento en
América Latina hay un aumento de la
población que tiene edad de trabajar y
eso podría ser digamos una oportunidad o
una ventana hacia el desarrollo
económico eh versus otros países como
por ejemplo en Italia donde aumenta la
población envejecida y donde Pues hay
una mayor carga para los Estados sobre
estas personas que ahora necesitan ser
en cierta parte sostenidas y que
necesitan de apoyo en vez de ser
personas productivas Entonces como de
nuevo le pregunto estamos en capacidad
de aprovechar ese momento y ese es
importante que lo aprovechemos pensando
en que hay que regular el crecimiento
poblacional pero al mismo tiempo
necesitamos pensar en las economías y
pues en la prosperidad y la calidad de
vida de la gente
efectivamente
en primer lugar cuando hablamos de
diferencias de crecimientos
poblacionales en un lugar y en otro en
pirámides de población envejecidas como
lo es la población europea en general y
no lo es América Latina cuando hablamos
de flujos migratorios primero hay que
poner sobre la mesa que emigrar siempre
un derecho Más allá de esas de las
misiones utilitaristas sobre los sobre
las necesidades o no de digamos de
trabajo de sostenimiento dicho esto es
cierto que el afrontándolo con En clave
de Justicia
global
hay necesidades o retos que enfrentan
los países cuyas poblaciones o pirámides
poblacionales cada vez se van
invirtiendo más y son más envejecidas
ante las cuales las pirámides de países
o de regiones enteras que ostentan o que
demuestran una incidencia mayor de
población jóvenes podrían solventar
hablamos de América Latina podría ser
ejemplo también Bueno pues en Nigeria
otros lugares con un crecimiento
exponencial que hoy están teniendo
bastante más digamos veloz
Pues bueno tienen pirámides de población
en población joven en edad Como
comentabas de trabajar y puede
precisamente ayudar a solventar los
retos que las poblaciones envejecidas
tienen por delante así que por un lado
tanto a nivel de políticas públicas
nacionales de países que tienen
pirámides poblacionales envejecidas como
el nivel de distribución Si se quiere
global de la población sería útil
barazar estas diferentes digamos
pirámides poblacionales pues mire Yo le
agradezco mucho a usted a Javi por la
información que nos entrega y el
análisis con un enfoque de derechos para
frases 24 y pues nos queda entonces la
duda sobre el planeta Cómo va a
sobrevivir en las condiciones actuales y
con un aumento poblacional que se prevé
siga y alcance su pico para el año 2080
y tal vez él valdría la pena
preguntarnos también con nuestros
televidentes si una distribución
diferente de los recursos se podría
ayudar en esta paradoja que nos
encontramos del crecimiento poblacional
muchas gracias a ustedes Javi por estar
con nosotros
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes